if Trump were easy to destroy
politically he would long ago be
destroyed the guy basically was involved
in an attempted Insurrection there seems
more and more evidence to support that
the thesis that he played a pretty bad
role in January the 6th it certainly
wasn't a good look even if if you take
the most benign reading he did something
pretty close to inciting that mob has
that hurt his chances no he's further
ahead as the front runner than almost
any candidate in recent contested
primaries so I have to say if if he can
get away with inciting an Insurrection
he can get away with having assaulted
somebody in the mid-1990s uh in a civil
case that just doesn't seem like a
career ending moment at all by Donald
Trump's standards